now you filmed this in south africa yes
now you've been there before right yeah
well uh not to work yeah okay yeah i
visited mr mandela i was invited to to
meet him and well how cool is that yeah
yeah i had i had well
i had breakfast
i had breakfast with archbishop desmond
tutu and lunch with nelson mandela wow
and actually when he came to the states
yeah the last time he came came to
california came to our house
well that's pretty good now you see that
i tell you a funny story too you'll be
mad at me for telling us but i'll tell
it anyway
uh sylvester stallone he lives up in the
we're like in a gated community he lives
over there and he he wasn't invited he
we had well i mean i would have invited
him but yeah we had about maybe 40 50
people there you know and i had my
children i said you can invite one
friend and you know oprah winfrey
different people were there
and the security they had security
helicopters like it was the president
yeah they're like mr washington uh uh
rocky's out front he's pacing
he's like
he's like looking in the gate
i said should we he's like should we let
him in i'm like yeah that's the best to
come in
they said he was outside looking sad
like
[Applause]
and good story my uh nephew thomas he
went to school one day and it was you
know talk about your family day and he
was telling all the school kids that his
uncle was superman and of course the
teacher then said thomas we don't lie in
school
we don't do that i appreciate good
storytelling yes but it's not a good
habit to get into and thomas was stood
by his guns but no no but my uncle is
superman and i swear he is i promise
and so she got upset with him uh he got
in trouble and then my sister-in-law was
pulled aside when she was picking him up
from school the teacher said look we
don't
we don't encourage our children to tell
lies in school
and i recommend that you would do the
same
and of course then she said about what
exactly
knowing that thomas is he does tell tall
tales
she was she was all in she's like oh no
not again right and then oh uh she was
saying that his uncle is superman she
went oh i hate to tell you this it's all
true right yeah you should speak at
career day yeah
i remember um those i'm afraid i'm going
to tell the story chris
no no no no
nothing happened that night that you
could say legally in public no
um there was some dancing involved and
uh but i remember looking back to um the
only two people in the club who weren't
dancing
and uh mrs evans and hemsworth
were i heard chris saying but how do you
get this that here
a fair question
and uh and chris hemsworth saying
i don't know mate like just work out and
stuff
to your brothers in arms i was surprised
you know shaquille o'neal yes in the
movie and it surprised me because i've
met him a bunch of times and he's such a
funny guy and you put him in the movie
you know to be an actor and he's funny
he's funnier than any of us yeah swear
to god there's all comedians in the
movie every time you do a scene
everybody walk away and go jack is
funnier than me
he's like the nicest
greatest guy
and we hung out with the shaq and we and
we all play basketball a lot of us on
the set that's right you're a fanatic
for basketball yeah you play it all the
time all the time and and uh the shacks
there so we're like let's let's play
ball with shaq so we play ball with shaq
full court running up and down shaq is
swatting shots on our face and we're
like yes
so happy so happy to get it's an honor
to be uh rejected by shaft exactly
okay then comes this thing so we play
basketball we got to get back to the
movie set
shaq has to take a shower
so
everyone's like all right we'll see you
later shag in my head i'm like i gotta
see shaq's penis
it's just it's just not
i can't i can't pass up that opportunity
i mean for historical reasons yeah it's
not not a gay thing it's just like you
got to see that yeah
so it's like the grand canyon you got to
see it
you got to see it you can't live and not
see it i get this completely thank you
so my plan was to kind of i hear the
shower go on in the back and i said all
right i'm just gonna in the back of what
in the locker room oh i thought you're
like in his trailer or something no
there's a gym we play basketball all
right so it's like at a high school and
he's showering away just not you know
being the shack down there in the
showers everyone else left i'm like all
right let me see that thing
i go back there i hear the shower i
start
i kind of turn around backwards and walk
backwards a little like walking
backwards because you want to look kind
of like i was going to trick him like i
just walked backwards and i saw it and i
was like hey what's up in there but no i
i'm walking backwards doing my routine
getting closer to the shower and then i
turn around and i go all right i'm going
to see
shaq's thing right now
his bodyguard is there
and his bodyguard is just so strong and
big
and like this thick neck
bald head
and this one eyes looking at me with
this one eye
so i said
sorry i was just
trying to
see shaq's penis
i apologize and i'm out of here uh-huh
please don't tell shaq okay this
happened so i see shaq later on the set
and i was like i guarantee that guy
ratted me out so i said
jack
sorry about that before with you
with your security guard and he goes i
don't got a security guard that was my
dick
most comedians are superstitious yeah
you think you you get that i'm not real
superstitious i won't circumnavigate the
globe if a black cat crosses my path so
i can come home in the other direction
or anything like that but i do carry
tuna in the truck that i can like spirit
them over and then paint them white oh i
see they get this well that's what that
makes but uh yeah a lot of comics are
you know i i used to in the old days
when i started out at yuck yucks right
uh i uh
i i always get to laugh yeah
i remember one night i used to whistle
in the dressing room all the time right
and it drove the other comics crazy
because they're very superstitious about
that sort of thing and one night it was
raining and there was a comic a
wonderful comic named lou dinos
well he was following me that night and
uh and i started whistling in the
dressing room and he started getting
upset so i opened up an umbrella
as well danced around whistling and he
said you don't do that man you just
don't do it okay it's one of those rules
man like that and i said ah the heck
weather man i went on stage and i
slaughtered i did the best i've ever
done i got a standing ovation and when i
came back off stage lou dinos was
standing there with an open umbrella
whistling
[Music]
the other day like um
uh the perfect example it was it was uh
it was probably about three weeks ago
and i was driving and i realized i was
on e
and i you know i had been paying i don't
be paying attention but i was like
i was on e and i was like oh no so i was
about you know 30 minutes from my house
so i pulled into the gas station and i
didn't have my wallet oh and i was like
oh tragedy right yeah so i'm looking and
i'm looking i was like well i cannot
call jada then she got to drive 30
minutes to come and i was like and i
looked over on the other side and i saw
a dude he was like 36 years old i was
like that dude is a fresh prince fan
[Laughter]
right you know
you can just spot them you can spot them
right you can spot them and i'm like you
know so i kind of rolled the window down
i was like
[Laughter]
you know after a couple minutes he was
like will oh yeah hey what's up man
what's up and he said hey man can i get
a picture i said yeah man i need about
ten dollars
it seems reasonable
and he was like really and he was like
really excited we took this selfie he
let me to ten dollars i was like give me
a number i'll send it back he's like
dude no way oh really no way that's
yours
i was like
we did these uh
sequences car chases and i know he
talked a little bit about it last night
but uh you know we did a scene in a in a
car it's driving 80 miles an hour in uh
in in cape town south africa really
really uh intense car chase and denzel
washington is in the back seat and uh
he's trying to choke me to death um he's
in the back seat he's just choking the
hell out of me as you do a lot in this
film uh and uh and you know the car is
zigging and zagging and it's all over
the place and somehow some way i felt uh
i felt the back of my head connect with
with something tall dark and expensive
oh and um yeah and uh
and we stopped the car and i i looked
around and and there was denzel
washington staring a hole through my
face yeah
and uh on his face he had a very large
growing uh golf ball sized welt you
mentioned that he did mention that i
know i'm aware of that you banged his
face with your head i banged my my i
banged his face very very hard with my
head which uh which uh uh for a young
actor that doesn't feel good
um
i didn't i didn't know what to do in the
moment you know i didn't know if i
should call for help um not for for him
for me
i i didn't know what uh yeah
okay uh biggest reality check i've had
i'm in vegas right i'm with an athlete
friend of mine yo you know ask me to
make a lot of money so we're there we're
hanging out keep in mind he makes more
money than me jay so i'm trying to keep
up with him sure whatever he does i'm
trying to do it okay so we go to a club
he got a table so i got a table he was
like yeah but we're together i said so
what i got money too i want my own table
that's what i told him i'm gonna spend
my own money i'm a man despite my size
right i'm growing okay so
we get there he got bottles i wanted to
get by back
yeah you know he had women come i didn't
have no women but at the time i was with
my aunt
it was my aunt's birthday you had your
aunt with me
it was her birthday right now uh i got
the bill i'm not gonna lie i didn't like
it you have you ever get a bill so high
you try to put it in the light like it's
going to change
it didn't change
nothing changed it was what it was
i had to talk to myself i said i said
kevin you know what just pay the bill go
to your room go to sleep so
i go to my room i go to sleep and here's
here's why i don't go out with athletes
no more the next morning uh i wake up my
friend and i was with he called me right
he was like kev last night was crazy i
said yo i had a ball he said well guess
what we're gonna do the same thing again
tonight and i was like you know i can't
i can't go twice because the weight of
my bank account is set up like you you
ever
no no
you ever start explaining your financial
situation to people for no reason at all
i said i would go but the way my account
is set up i gotta i got a checking in
the savings but all the money is in my
savings yeah so i gotta i gotta switch
it to the check-in but it takes three
business days
at this at this point in time that's all
and it's true
yeah two steps jay it's two stories out
of you have you got a lot of celebrity
friends you hang out i got celebrity
friends it's the same thing i don't i
don't deal with those guys i don't i
don't deal with celebrities either i've
had once again reality checks you know
uh mccain pfeiffer i don't know if you
guys know mikayla oh sure yeah i'm top
five terrific actor a great actor yeah
good friend of mine okay this is the
biggest reality check i've ever hit with
my life makai calls me he says kev my
son's birthday party is saturday he said
you want to come to the party i said
cool he said bring your daughter that's
why i'm inviting you all right i get
there it's at disneyland him and his son
are out front he got his son hand i
don't see nobody else at the park so i'm
like dude i thought he said was a party
he said it is it's just us i bought the
park out for the day
and i said okay what you mean you bought
the park out like like there's still
people in the park he said no it's just
us like we got it for like eight hours
um so i said you know before i go in did
you pay for this already are you looking
for help cause i'm not here
no no i'm serious i'm not
i'm not in a position where i can help
you because the weight of my the weight
of my bank account yeah
[Applause]
you know i know dwyane wade he uh he's a
friend of yours yes he was he was
talking about you uh dwyane wade is
another good friend of mine wayne tried
to mess up
dwayne he didn't no no dwayne dwayne
tried to make me buy a boat i don't even
have a house i said hey man
i told him
i told him that i said hey i don't have
a house i don't think this is a good
purchase he's like you should just get
it right i was like no i would but the
weight of my bank account is set up
it's a checking in the savings right but
all the money is in my savings right i
can't i can't transfer it out my savings
that fast it's three business days three
businesses
i don't want to be on the phone that
long